So what exactly do we need to
know to get a widget working?
How does the launcher even know we have
a widget the user could choose to add to
their home screens?
There's two main pieces.
An AppWidgetProvider XML file and
an AppWidgetProvider class.
The AppWidgetProvider XML file Is what
describes your widget's attributes,
such as its size,
whether it can be resized, and
a preview image, which helps users get a
sense of what your widget will look like
before adding it to their home screen.
The AppWidgetProvider is
what holds all the logic for
creating the actual widget views,
filling the views with the correct data
and setting up the click listeners so
our widgets respond to touch.
One thing to keep in mind is that
users aren't limited to just
one instance of your widget.
They could have a bunch of
different sized widgets with
potentially different data.
That's one reasons why part of your
AppWidgetProviderInfo can specify
a configuration activity,
a special one-time setup activity that
appears when users select your widget.
Well, we won't use this for Sunshine.
You can imagine,
if Sunshine supported multiple locations
at once, we could use a configuration
activity to select which location we
wanted to display in each widget.
So, let's start simple.
We'll build the one by one version of
our today widget with some static data,
say sunny and 76 degrees Fahrenheit,
a nice 24 Celsius.
What would our app widget
provider info look like?
In fact,
there's only a few required attributes.
First here is initialLayout.
This is the XML layout
to be used by default.
minHeight and
minWidth are what determine how many
cells in the launcher are used.
Note that the number and size of cells
can change based on the device or
launcher being used.
A good rule of thumb is this formula,
which works well for
all default launchers.
In any case, you should build your
widget such that it's flexible
enough to support slight
variations in the size available.
The last attribute, you can see here,
is the updatePeriodMillis.
By default, the system will wake up your
device at approximately this interval,
and call your app widget
provider update your widget,
with a minimum update
period of a half hour.
However, if you have static data,
you don't want to wake up
the data if it's in deep sleep.
Or, if you have another component
already controlling the flow of new data
into your app, such as
Sunshine Sync Adapter, you can use 0 to
disable this functionality and
prevent unnecessary work.
That's all we need to get started.